fans of the show know we love bud light
seltzer they are the presenting sponsor
you know about bud light seltzer it's a
delicious hard seltzer from bud light
with no bud light in it each one is only
100 calories 5 alcohol by volume and
gluten free and now they get the perfect
flavors for summer with the bud light
seltzer lemonade variety pack and the
brand new bud light seltzer iced tea
variety pack you can try them together
which christian did the other day and
make your ideal alcoholic arnold palmer
or dive into the good vibes of
yesteryear with a retro summer pack and
retro summer icicles there's that cherry
limeade that's my favorite flavors and
you know you can combine there's a peach
iced tea and lemonade you combine those
together get a peach arnold palmer stay
tuned to hear more about bud light
seltzer's newest offerings and a little
more about us and our summer memories
later in the show but now the show
[Music]
i went to college faster college really
loved it i lived just off campus above a
restaurant that i loved called chan's
peking
it was a chinese restaurant i lived in
the very top floor it was like the third
floor the first time i had my own place
and underneath me was
an apartment where all my friends lived
and there was always something going on
there a party and somebody coming over
and they we had a dog that we all loved
and it was just there was just so much
life there i mean it was crowded you
might say it was a full house
but always so fun and every morning i
smell general so's chicken wafting
through the floorboards that that's the
cherry on the sunday for you to me
that's the sunday
but uh the cherry was fun too and
speaking of fun sundays
enjoy this ear sunday life could be a
dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
you're listening to life is short i'm
your host who's a little rusty justin
long
life could be a dream sweetheart
i'm feeling uh really wobbly right now
about this introduction how do you feel
oh oh i should introduce you i feel
pretty bad yeah
with me as always is my bad feeling
brother and co-host christian let's pick
it up okay let's do it have you ever
lived in a place that was a little
crowded but you look back and god there
were fun times you know as fate would
have it as you were telling that story i
was
half listening yeah kind of you tell his
story yeah and thinking
when i was in college
i lived in a rather crowded place once
one year it was called the asian
interest house there were certain houses
had like theme houses which just meant
you were interested in asian things
there was the peace studies house there
was the creative arts house there there
were certain houses that had oh themes
the general theme how would you end up
in the asian interest house i'll tell
you how it was the only a way i could
get a single
a room
because i was pretty low down in the
housing lottery so it was the only my
only opportunity to have a single oh
interesting anywhere on campus was in
the asian interest house and not that i
know you're interested in asian things i
i i wasn't not interested yeah exactly
but i didn't do it for nothing
in asia right but then nothing would
preclude you from being a part of that
themed house so we've both lived in full
houses at certain points
of our lives what are you drinking
you know why you know ironically i was
trying to avoid look at how many ice
cubes are in there yeah so i didn't want
to take a big loud sip during the
podcast why i did it i didn't want to
watch this
oh wait it's not doing it now i didn't
want it to do that jostle around the ice
that's much less defensive than what you
did do which is well well because i in
an effort to not move the cup a lot i
moved my lips onto it and like
like why are we talking about full house
yeah and full lips
um i have full lips wouldn't you say so
do i you don't both have to full lips
you don't have to be defensive about it
i didn't suggest that you don't anyway
yeah why are we talking about full house
tell you why because when we were
growing up
there was an iconic
tv show
on
called full house it was yeah family
matters it was part of tgif and it was a
great show but now it's known to a whole
new generation of viewers
um
through because of netflix right isn't
it on netflix and there's a new show
they did a spin-off called fuller house
we're just telling people things they
already know fuller house is a massive
well i mean it was a massive hit on
netflix it makes sense because again
like you said it's an iconic show and we
are fortunate enough to have one of the
iconic
stars of that iconic show
john stamos you didn't really know him
before you talked to him but now you are
well acquainted with him yeah we're
i think we're friends buddies no we're
not friends we're acquaintances john
stamos aside from being on full house
has been in
you know he works
he's worked constantly for he's decades
and stuff who doesn't know john yeah
everyone knows john stamos and now
uh he's going to be known as a podcast
host he's hosting
a show on wandery
snatching sinatra yeah i can't wait to
listen to it it's not just because it's
our
a parent company what would you call it
our company our company
we work for them yeah and uh but it does
sound really interesting he's gonna talk
about that and of course we don't
mention full house that he's lying
justin's long uh but also
he has a show on disney plus called big
shot
where um he's getting rave reviews he
plays a basketball coach a girls team
basketball coach should we hear from him
i think so here's my
my talk my chat with
the iconic john stamos life could be a
dream sweetheart
hello hello again so we'll meet
[Music]
again john how sick are you people
saying oh my god you look amazing you
look so handsome
sick of it yeah i bet i would rather
someone say
you're that was funny you know uh the
ipad justin john why chaco
uh i don't know it was always just sort
of a uh a pseudo name and now it's
ruined because we've talked about now oh
sorry
i always sometimes go by like jocko
stamps because my because spell check
corrects stamos to stamps oh that makes
sense stamps yeah
justin i'm a fan of yours i'm happy to
meet you i don't think we i don't
believe we've met before
we we have um but i think
they were under like somewhat hazy
circumstances uh
so it's not even worth
mentioning even though i just did was i
was
we were both a little you know there's
drinks happening and
in the old days yeah the old days were
we nice to each other oh totally oh man
yeah uh no in fact
i remember having a lot of fun
where was it but now we're out here at
the bauer isn't that funny when like
people remember and this happens
i know you've had this experience many
times but people will remember something
that you probably found or you didn't
even it didn't even imprint because it
was probably such a
innocuous interaction you know and
they'll say oh we met what do you mean
we met don't you remember phil 14 years
ago in passing at the [ __ ] premiere
of the thing well i would remember you i
and
yeah that that happened it's usually but
the other
the other way that works is like if you
have this thing that you think you did
something really shitty to somebody or
you're a real jackass and you just you
can't let it go you can't let it go and
they didn't remember at all
exactly they didn't internalize it in
nearly the same way i just witnessed
that happening between two
women actually one of whom said um
one woman complimented the other on her
hair
and and the one who received the
compliment said well just have a kid you
know i when i had a kid my hair got very
robust and and the next day
the the the one with the child and the
nice hair came to the other one and said
i
feel so bad for what i did right and the
other one was like what are you talking
about you know like she had shamed her
for not even kids anyway um was it drew
barrymore it was it was no how do you
stay friends with all these girls that
you've dated oh do you not start with
that
you don't huh um
i find it very easy yeah here's what it
is the most likable guy on the planet
next to paul rudd i think oh well i
don't know paul's pretty nice that's
nice you just say i like being i like i
enjoy people i like being nice but i um
but i also like there's something about
you know certainly in the case of drew
when you're with somebody long enough um
there's there's something about
not being friends afterwards or at least
staying in touch in some way that is so
monumentally depressing to be to me that
that you could that you could spend that
much time with somebody and then
uh i have one ex that i that i i don't
get along with unfortunately and i wish
i did um
but i think all the other ones for the
you know you know it ranges from like
we're fine with each other too like true
in drew's case we're friends
were you heartbroken i mean that's
usually when it it's hard to become to
be stay friends right yeah there's an
ugly you know copper divorce but that's
it's john to me that stuff doesn't
calcify that stuff is like those are
emotions that kind of that that
dissipate um
usually with in my case pretty quickly
um have you ever been heartbroken just
your heart just busted wide open
yeah but i i think it was more uh ego
based i don't think it was like in other
words i don't regret any of the
breakups i don't think there's i don't
think like there's one that got away or
right right maybe one yeah
but
you know i think that's the key if in
hindsight it once the dust settles
you're able to see it clearly which i
think i can with all of those
relationships i or clear enough to know
that it wasn't the right thing if
somebody goes a different way and and
you're not their pers as they say on the
bachelor their person um then uh then
that's it it's like yeah
there's something about being in love
that is so exciting because it's like a
a connectivity between two people and if
you're just not connected i don't see i
don't see what you're mourning i don't
see what you would be grieving i guess
the loss of the former connection but
it's already gone
how old are you
i'm 42 i'm before you actually i'm 43
wink wink because this will be
airing that's a good age 43 it must be
tough for you because i mean
in my case as well because we both look
young uh i mean you don't look like
you've aged much and i
i wonder if how much of it can be
attributed to the greek heritage you
still have a ton of hair and stuff like
that but does that lend itself to
do you think just psychologically
staying because this has always been my
problem is staying in this
perpetual adolescence you know that not
really being able to commit in a major
way uh growing up and all that that's
tough for me yeah 100
it took me a long long time i'm i'm 57
now she's wow but it took me it took me
a long time to it's the peter pan
syndrome yeah and our lives are you know
we're so blessed we're so lucky and and
you know most of my life i've had people
taking care of my money and taking care
of this you know you you probably had
the same deal and so you really there
weren't those tent poles that say you're
an adult now you've got to do right do
that people are taking care of it but
which is which was detrimental to me
because i eventually yeah you know i
bottomed out i i you know i was drinking
too much hang and i got yeah ui to rehab
i was like come on man to grow up it it
it's it's sad i mean i went into it
kicking screaming because
it um it's a it's a sad thing to let go
and like you said you and i have you
know we could hold on to it a lot longer
yeah but in order to have the next
beautiful phase which was you know
having a child and getting married i had
to let all that stuff go i had to let i
had to grow up that's interesting it's
it's interesting about that john because
you as it relates to your just to looks
i i don't want to harp on that but but
it is in in this case i think part of
the equation is that you
in fact when i saw you last and yeah
well i'll say we were drawn we were
drinking we were there like like how
many years ago six seven oh
probably about that yeah 2012 2013
something like that
but it was
you know it struck me that like
you didn't see you didn't look like a
guy who had a problem you didn't
and i mean that in a very superficial
way like you know oftentimes you see
those those people with real drinking
problems it's like oh they look like a
mess or they're
they're they're treating people a
certain way that's like kind of um there
was you've always in my
estimation been charming enhanced all
that all those superficial things um so
it must have been it must have delayed
that what you you have what you just
described as as a certain inevitability
you know uh in terms of getting clean
getting sober
yes
you're saying that well yeah i think a
lot of people said i didn't really know
you had a problem yeah you know i did i
kept it down and then also you know i'd
straighten up for months before having
to work and we didn't let into work and
it was just you know it was just time
yeah
but the but i think
the youthful look that we both have
maybe to you know just to be
honest has helped the longevity in the
career for me i think oh god right yeah
yeah for sure i mean we uh i it's how i
started i mean i was able to get work
because i was
i was older i think i was a little bit
and i was but i was able to play these
high school
i did dodgeball when i was 25 24. wow
and that was written for a 15 year old i
heard your interview with vince vaught
it was so fascinating
you were great with him and a little fan
girly but
for sure but you guys were dissecting
comedy and it was so fascinating because
i love i love the the science of comedy
i love stand-up comics you know don
rickles was a father to me and we could
talk about oh did you know him oh no i'm
he was he was i was very very close with
him you're kidding oh i john it's i
don't know if i've talked about it on
vince's episode but um
i i've been i've been talking about it a
lot on the show i for some for whatever
reason i keep going back and watching
those old carson interviews and his
roasts and his like his appearances on
the talk show i love don
he comes up all the time on the show he
never got to meet him i met him briefly
with sam rockwell this guy chris messina
um i think he was really laying it on
heaviest with sam but it was um yeah he
insulted all of us it was perfect it's
what you want in that meeting it was
called me a [ __ ]
you know some italian slur and then yeah
i was uh my my father passed away to you
know he was 65 it was a pretty early age
wow and i was always sort of looking to
replace that that father figure it
started with actually with although my
dad was still alive during the time i
worked with jack klugman early on wow
and
gary marshall was like like a second
father and then you know then dawn dawn
was a guy you know i met him a few times
over the years but we were at a greek
restaurant and i happened to be sitting
with this big you know park my table was
kind of next to his and all the people
were talking and his people were talking
we just turned to each other just
started talking talking and it was
during a time when he you know i think a
lot of people just thought he was dead
they didn't really realize he was around
and still super funny and people had
forgotten about him i mean he was doing
some shows in vegas nobody really paid
attention so i was like well i can get
your number or can i take out a launch
show or you know and then we just became
very very close and then he had sort of
a resurgence that we did that
documentary about him and and people
started really realizing like yeah late
like oh my god look at this guy that was
like 2008 right that documentary around
then 2017
wow he was um
yeah until the very end he was just we
would he'd call me we talked for hours
like two years
that's incredible talk about fangirling
i would have lost my mind on him i
really miss him he was just so brilliant
it was a way to feel connected to your
dad too i mean that's bad yes yeah yeah
wow he my mom was still around a lot
during that time he loved my mom he you
know he called her a drunk or something
funny you know he was at my 50th
birthday he just got up and sliced late
everybody oh my god how amazing and
people lost it right people loved it oh
my god he just seems like he really
lived his life in in a way that i i
admire i don't know
he had this incredible love story with
his wife too who just passed away like
two months ago a month that's right
barbara you'd say to to don you'd say
that barbie say how are you doing and
she said we're good we're good not i'm
good it's the two of us and uh yeah we
talked about it all the time yeah and he
made fun of her and he made fun of her
all the time and he you know we were
talking about relationships earlier and
the best ones i've had and and ones i'm
excited about are always the ones where
you can tease each other you can really
let each other have it those are the
best you have to but i guess you have to
be able to take it yourself right and
you got to take the perception which i
do and my wife loves to do with me
um
she's funny
my first date with one of my first dates
to disney uh we went to disney world
and i'm thinking which is the complete
opposite of now i know what this girl
would be impressed by but i'm kind of
not i had a hat i had glasses on i'm not
really getting recognized i'm kind of
looking around i'm trying to take my
glasses off
you know nothing so i take my hat off
you know
and and she said what are you doing i
said nothing she goes you're you're
you're epcotting because we were in
epcot what is that you're trying to get
recognized you're epcotting so whatever
you know whatever that comes up i mean
funny john i was just thinking about
like
how i asked your question how are you
able to stay friends with your exes and
um
and i thought uh you know at the heart
of every good
relationship is a friendship i think
and your friends
your friends for
for the most part um
and so that kind of stuff i'm really
like forgiving a friend you know if
anything happens to me i i hope i
attract people who are likewise
forgiving and so i think that's how it
sustains itself it's just a friendship
makes sense well us you know supposedly
like uh you know bon vivants or you know
dudes were out there chasing all the
girls and stuff you were sneaking
secretly sneaking in and getting all the
smart beautiful women and you were more
of a player than anybody
and uh i admire that i think
well
i don't know if that's yeah nice to be
honest you were i mean i i you know
there's always something this is also a
limitation um is that i it's always been
a
problem for me is because i love people
i love meeting new people i love the
idea of getting to know different people
um
so real long-term commitment was always
hard i can't even say the word
do you want kids i do i do
you see you should want to be a great
dad i was surprised to learn this was
your first oh thanks for saying that i i
feel that way about you you must it must
be fun
yes it was certainly because i again
going back to the you know growing up
and peter panson or whatever yeah uh i i
wasn't you know i don't think i could
handle it
you know any time sooner right um but
just stability too john like the
stability of because you know our jobs
are and even more so with you because it
sounds like you were always doing
something i mean not just acting you had
touring and stuff like that is different
i mean
you seemed like you were always
off doing something is that is that a
misrepresentation no that's right and it
would have been hard to have you know a
kid during a lot of the during a lot of
that time i'm still doing shows with the
beach boys i'm playing
i just played in san diego at a big uh
at the basement there's a big they're
the best men now
they're yeah i'm the only boy yeah i
just i'm the only boy now i'm not the
only one how what is that like that must
be wild i mean god because i imagine
they were heroes of yours growing up
this has been going on since 84. oh my
god
somewhere around there 84 with you
yeah
how did that come to be
it is so funny because just right now
for some reason everybody's really
fascinated by it's been happening since
you know for three right years um
i was a fan you know i i love the music
grew up in orange county and and uh my
first concert i ever went to was the
beach boys it just was
just you know in me and i i um i had a
friend who was playing guitar with the
band jeffrey foskett and and i went to
the it was they're playing at padres
stadium and i went to the show and went
and um the show had ended but they
hadn't done their encore yet and uh i
came i was going to backstage and all
these cheerleaders and girls chased me
into the backstage and they were
screaming and and my club turns my
friend said who's that well that's my
friend john stanley who's on general
hospital did the girls always follow him
around like that he said yeah he goes
get him on stage
and then
i played uh like just at the you know on
the encore barbarian and then i just i
never i never left i just
obsessive wait a minute first of all
that's a great mike love impression how
did they know that you could play
yeah well i i was a you know i wanted to
be a musician so i was a decent drummer
yeah um and they had two drummers always
dennis wilson had just died there's a
couple guys and there was so i just kind
of i don't know how i have really no
great explanation other than i just kind
of weaseled my way in at the time
you know in the 80s there were there was
a lot there was the wilson side and love
yeah you know on stage there was maybe
16 17 people seriously and i remember
one time i think it was well mike said
hey why don't you just play the whole
show play percussion okay and then
carl's singing godly nose or uh
and he's like he looked at me like who's
who's that okay yeah wow but we later
became you know very close so this was
even before full so i didn't know
general hospital was when people
that it was you were that
poppy i mean people knew you enough to
like
attract that kind of attention that mike
love would have well you you probably
weren't born but that when i was a teen
you know i was 18 years old i was a
teenager
that sounds lame but no that was just my
teen island time and you know that show
it was my first job and and that show
was
um you know 30 million people watched it
everyone oh my god like it's a great
place to start because
i had at one point i had 30 pages a day
oh my character got very popular god
they they put
gloria monty was this brilliant um
producer and she kind of uh re-energized
the face of daytime television she
brought on these younger people and gave
it energy and movement and then all of a
sudden you probably remember like people
were scheduling their college you know
classes around it it was huge in the 80s
yeah and on for general hospital i
i was playing the street kid named
blackie i was like hey you know like a
thing and i didn't he was supposed to be
from new york
yeah that was this uh you know i was
this street urchin
were you doing an accident like uh in
new york well here's the deal i've never
been to new york oh you know i saw the
bowery boys or something and i i wanted
to like get the walk down because i was
like hey i gotta get a walk you know
like a stripe
yeah like a travolta or something but
you know and so i borrowed my mother's
uh leather jacket you know
because i lived in orange county and i
went up to i was driving around
hollywood and i was looking around santa
monica boulevard
which is sort of boys town which i
didn't know at the time i said this
looks like new york i'm gonna get out
and work on my walk oh no knocking and
it's like chumming the waters
well now as i look back and i'm trying
i'm just walking funny and i'm doing
this [ __ ] and then i buy a i think you
know what i'm gonna i need a bandana
because i'm gonna tie it around like
cha-ching oh boy i'm going to need some
ends too
yeah
and i get this bandana yellow and i go
and i audition and the casting director
says you know do you know what that um
what that bandana means i'm like i don't
know i'm trying you know chachi hey you
know bruce breezy yeah springsteen yeah
no it means it's it means you like to be
peed on like what
what i'm 18 years old you know wait get
this off me wait wait what color was it
where were you wearing it yellow it was
yellow i guess there's a thing where
different different uh bandanas yeah
mean different things i know
i usually wear a brown one around my
midsection right
wait anyway so i left after two years
because i always wanted to be in comedy
i wanted i wanted to do happy days like
those were that's you know speaking of
gary marshall yeah that was my um my
where i wanted to get to it
um but i played music too and they
wouldn't let me play drums on the show
because they didn't know and i was like
every week i said can i play drums like
no there was a there was sammy davis jr
came out and did about two weeks on the
show danny davis jr was on general
hospital yes yeah what so
so
i figured you'd like the old school guys
right i know we're going to talk about
sinatra
yes gotta talk about sinatra yeah um but
i wanted to play music and and there was
this set
it was like a
orchestra a big band was playing and
there were drums and you know stuff and
sammy and i was hosting this this talent
show we were raising money for the docks
the kids on the docks on the street kids
and sammy was playing somebody's father
and he was going to sing on this thing
and i introduced him anyway before the
scene i was i didn't know who sammy
davis junior was and i asked my dad and
he's like oh my god he's great talk to
him about drums talk to him because he
played drums so i talked about drumming
and and i said you know they won't let
me play on here and he's like ow
yeah and he goes uh and then he goes
back to the booth the producer comes
back out and says all right just do what
i say man and i'm like what and i
remember this so clearly that he was
like just do what i say in the in the
middle of the scene i guess you're
saying so he gets on and he says uh he
says blackie you play drums right and
i'm like what and they cut to me and my
i'm just like beaming and i go up and i
start playing drums he's playing piano
this jazz thing
and we didn't practice it or it was just
nothing and
god first of all that he wow what that's
a [ __ ] great story john that he
because with soap operas too like they
they don't really film them multiple
times they don't do many takes right no
so was that so that was it were the
producers i'm just imagining tootsie
that's that's my frame of reference for
you yeah right right you back up a
little bit yeah i love cleveland
yeah you and your brother love these
movie courses let me say real fast i i
know i'm jumping all the way your
brother when i looked you guys up when i
looked you up today he has a sense of
humor by himself right oh yeah i can't
wait for this now
i don't mean to sound like a [ __ ]
but so i see pictures of you with him
and you with him and i go wow justin has
a wax figure at a museum now i'm jealous
of him i thought it was your wax figure
that you were posing with but it was
your brother because i mean he's he
looks like you but he's he's a little
more pale yeah and he's he's just as
handsome but a little he's really funny
he's he's gonna love this oh i don't no
no no it's not i don't know
no no no and then i realized it was your
brother's like oh what an [ __ ] no
that's funny no we do look
it's really funny
everybody can use a little less stress
right a way that i've found to deal with
my stress is caliper caliper is a cbd
powder that dissolves almost immediately
in water it doesn't taste like anything
though there are flavored caliper
packets i feel the effects within 10 to
15 minutes i feel less stress i feel a
calmness
it helps you sleep and it's totally
natural it delivers 30 times more cbd
than uh cbd oil does it's the only
clinically proven fast-acting cbd so
there's research behind this developed
by food science experts with decades of
experience it's all been rigorously
tested for purity and quality and
there's precisely 20 milligrams in each
packet it's always thc free that's
important to note so you won't get high
right it's all natural vegan non-gmo it
there's no fillers added chemicals
artificial flavors
it's all natural if you like those
things if you like added chemicals and
artificial flavors you know this might
not be for you so get 20 off your first
order when you use the promo code long
at
try caliper.com
long you can try caliper risk free for
30 days if you don't love it they'll
just give you a full refund that's try
caliper.com
long don't forget promo code long for 20
off your first order
hello hello
[Music]
you know i got into
well i love acting since i was a kid but
i think i also really wanted to be
famous when i was a kid my friend just
reminded me of this that my best friend
we would go to knott's berry from
disneyland and i would make him run up
to to me and ask me for my autograph and
then people would say who is that
night sign
yeah it was terrible oh no it's not it's
honest i think a lot of people harbor
those uh
you know they cover that kind of stuff
but sometimes people say oh you're so
nice you're so nice it was like
i wanted to be famous you know my whole
life so might as well just enjoy it
right well then i i would imagine with
that mentality especially at that age
when you're when you're a teen idol
you're it's in the 80s you're handsome
guy you're literally you're pinned up on
magazines at what point does that stop
feeding you you know about it yesterday
sometime yesterday about 2pm oh wow
what a red letter day um pretty early on
i mean that's when you know
full house was a you know a double-edged
sword because it was you know made me
famous and and provided a beautiful life
for me and my family uh we got to do a
lot of things but you know you know but
then you're not taking serious as an
actor so right
right it was somewhere around there and
i remember talking to jack klugman about
i said what do i do
and he said
theater get to the theater
and i was never
i can't i'm not a singer i don't like to
sing i'm not good at it i have to work
really really hard and dancing too but
then again having that mentalities like
well i'll just practice 10 hours a day
i'll just take lessons yeah lessons
and i did i i went to new york and i
auditioned
now here's balls right i've never been
on really on stage i've never been on
broadway i've never been on an off
broadway i've never been in a musical
and i went uh an audition to replace
matthew broderick and how to success
right that's right what the [ __ ] was i
thinking you know and then i blasted
into the room and i'm ah
you know do we play it the cup and i got
the role in that oh
and then i just did it it was like oh
wow john what so and that was was it uh
direct klugman advice is that where it
came from was it like i got a deuce i
got to move the needle i got to change
this up a little bit
well i i don't know i i don't know and i
i try to get back to that fearlessness
all the time i see on my new show uh
these these girls these young girls are
are some of them you know are extremely
new and they just come on and you know
fearless fearlessness
it's and you know you probably get it
too it's like over the years you start
listening to people and you start
watching yourself you start overthinking
[ __ ] i'm finally at the point where i
don't give a [ __ ] anymore and i just dig
into the writing you know david kelly oh
right it's big shot i just want to point
it's on disney plus it's you're getting
incredible reviews so you're doing some
wherever your head's at now i feel like
that's uh that's where you should try to
try to capture it's taken it took me a
while again going back to you know just
you know leaving a lot of stuff behind
yeah what did you always do voices uh i
always like to do
impressions i guess i was fascinated by
voices yeah what's your who's your best
who's um well you know when i was a kid
it would be family members it would be
uh friends and teachers and stuff like
that uh you're like fallon you look like
fallon a little bit oh that's great
thank you so that's thanks for saying
that buddy
that's so cool that's so cool so fun i
gotta talk to you about full house uh
that looks great you look like him too
when you do that very funny part
uh somebody just said to oh it's decided
dave dude company said uh it's it's
inhabited he said i just think about the
person and he was talking about doing
snl and he said um he was so afraid that
like he was being asked to do actually
jeff goldblum and jeff goldblum and
president said god what if i'm not able
to think about jeff when the cameras are
on you know because it's just something
that's when he's comfortable for friends
um
but i yeah the first one i ever did was
max wright from alph
was were those guys you ever crossed
past with i'm just thinking about like
no you're on iconic i thought all the
puppets sitcom actors back then knew
each other um i also heard you and your
brother talking about the word iconic
and not overusing it so let's keep it oh
well i would say full house is an iconic
tv
show the thing i'm curious about you is
and in terms of this new show in terms
of big shot on disney plus
is that you now have the luxury and i
think it is it's there is something
luxurious about it
good writing you know david davidy kelly
like one of the best there is a real
difference like there's a real i know
that feeling of when you can just be
present to something and especially
knowing what you've gone through now
that that you're
you know you're in recovery and and this
character sounds like i'm sure it sounds
like there's some parallels with the
character that was probably made it
really exciting to dive into
i didn't think there were but then as
the more i played him the more they came
up and also the more i learned from him
like yeah you know i i've i've
you think you got to do your put your
very best into everything every every
day but then after doing that speech
about you know at the end of the day if
you can look in the mirror and say i did
my best yeah it's you know it's it's
he says uh he says life is is difficult
and it's hard and and you don't have a
fighting chance unless you fight and i
don't mean you know i mean fight for it
and
now i look at at the end of the day i go
did i did my best at everything now it's
kind of shitty with this
half-assed and that's the thing too um
it's just uh
giving it your all now yeah like you
know what he talks about but i think
i've been doing that more the last few
years you say i'm in a good place i
think it's because
you know for the long time i got i got
by with 60 70 right i was still better
than most right
yes right and it's lazy and it's you
know it's like it didn't you know and
yeah i'll be fine i'll get i don't have
to study as hard
john i know that feeling and you asked
about looking back at some earlier stuff
and that's the one thing that i really
do regret about my work about the work
is that i look back and i think that
like you know i stayed out the night
before i remember like i i i didn't
really
know i wasn't respectful of how lucky i
was to be in that position to get to one
of us none of us were right yeah right
right but now i think we're all
appreciated i mean i don't want to speak
for anyone else but i know i'm
appreciating things a lot more now god
i'm so grateful too i'm so grateful
because
especially going through the last year
and a half and you know having a job you
know we shot half of it through that
time oh wow what a privilege it was yeah
to be able to get to work yeah it was
difficult and it wasn't you know but
wait going back to to
yeah because you feel like i'm sure you
could give 67 after a while you give 60
percent and like you're great especially
certain parts certain parts it's like oh
i know this guy this guy got this yeah
yeah yeah and then yeah and i imagine
i i cuz i love doing uh multicams but i
never done one certainly not as long as
you have but i've never done one even
for a year you know i i'll come in and
do a couple episodes so i love it but i
i imagine i have friends who have done
successful ones and they say versions of
you know one friend said you start to
coast at a certain point you start to
yeah you know um
and was that that must feel what does
that feel like i mean not that idea that
you did that but like well i certainly
did i mean a lot of these shows you do
because and it's not not necessarily
always coasting you you have to
you have to conserve something yeah
yourself a little bit too you can't like
blow out every i mean you but that's the
difference between giving 100 and giving
60 or 70 right you go like you know i
got a same with theater right you go ah
i got it's got another show tonight
maybe i shouldn't give it all yeah
and that's the difference between you
know brilliant brilliant performers and
you know me
but i'm trying to get back i'm trying to
do that i'm trying to do that here the
fear too is that maybe you feel this i
know i do is like if i do give it a 100
and i suck
then i have no excuse yes exactly but
now i'm at the point where it's like
okay if i suck and i give him a hundred
percent then [ __ ] that's me
that's what i can do after how uh how to
succeed in business i went back like
four or five times and some of them were
great success some weren't i did i
replaced uh antonio banderas in nine i
was i turned 40.
i loved about 20 and i i tanked it i
closed the show after a few months and i
just didn't it wasn't you know i didn't
have it
it's okay to give 100 and fail it's
things because you know i'm not afraid
of that anymore i'd rather and most of
the time you won't if you give
everything you got it's gonna you're
gonna be okay you've alluded to this
john but how much of that how much of
that work ethic and that drive was born
out of
the full house experience and and the
the cementing of your name
in that context like that john stamos is
the guy from full house how much of it
was like i'm gonna chip away at this i'm
gonna do whatever i can to break out of
that
i had it way before i mean you did i got
on all those shows because i had it
before from my father right my dad
worked and my dad owned fast food places
and he restaurants and he wanted me to
take over the business and i didn't go
to a bougie college like you i wouldn't
got in i barely i couldn't i went to go
to the local cypress college and i
couldn't find the sign up room and that
sure came back yeah i was doing i didn't
come
i wasn't a very academical yeah like
your family it was
you know and and that's always plagued
me i always feel that i'm not quite as
smart i'm always like not the smartest
guy in the room well that's funny john
that's interesting you say that because
i had the same insecurities i still do
because my older brother was the smart
one i mean he's the one that went to
princeton oh god yeah
but you come off very smart very
articulate very passionate very it's all
an act connected well that you're doing
a great job ken
um
so wait so we were talking about this
well you went to you when you dropped
out then
no i didn't even go in
you got to go next up he wanted me just
to learn business you have to go next
semester or that's it you know you have
to and so i was like oh please get on tv
please come on oh that was like your one
way out then
yeah yeah and i
auditioned and i when i got the role in
general hospital and i was my dad said
you still you have to work you're my
sunday guy you got to work on you got i
need you sundays i go dad
so i would so i would do general
hospital during the week and then work
on the at the restaurant yeah out of
here what was the restaurant what fast
food place it was called yellow basket
and burger basket and dukes they were
like fast food places
and
but the show started to air
those soap operas only a few weeks out
so now you're working at burger
basketball i'm working there and people
you know say hey i'll take a cheap
aren't you the guy oh my god give me two
i'm like dad i'm famous i got it i got
to be done but it was it was that work
ethic yes that i think that i got and
you know and also i i'll
forever be in debt my dad treated the
guy the kid in the back washing dishes
the same way he treated his best
customers that's correct and i never
forgot the way he talked to people but
also then yes the fire to prove people
that i could do you know more than just
uncle jesse stuff but i'll tell you man
i the last show i did was
called last show i did was called the
best man with james earl [ __ ] jones
okay oh wow oh my god arguably the best
actor on the planet oh my god and um it
was a political show boy it would really
work right now uh but i i'm on stage
with him angela lansbury oh my god john
uh laricat
great you know great cast great people i
love larry um
and
got good reviews you know and i'm i'm
i'm literally it's a you know three-act
play so i'm on stage oh you know a lot
with james earl jones do you have any
could james earl jones stories oh yeah
he was about star wars
i'm not a star wars guy you probably no
oh oh yeah
uh
no and and people would always try to
get him to do you know luke oh yeah in
fact we would we would we would do a
warm-up before the show and one of the
act one of the
actors in the show would conduct it and
there'd be 10 or 20 of us in the theater
before and it was like me may mom mo you
know
and then he would try this but
luke i am your father look i mean
you'd walk into a restaurant with him
and the place would stop and he was you
know as a big talker yeah so there was a
moment in the scene that we had towards
the beginning of this talk about
gravitas yeah yeah he had feet like and
he would he was that act he was the kind
of actor that would just sort of go with
whatever was happening and one time he
was in the theater like stomping his
feet in the middle of a scene which had
no stomping in oh wow weird and i and
i go what are you and he starts so what
happened i was trying to get a titsy fly
it was like some weird you know fruit
flies yeah oh my god but there was a
moment in the scene where he didn't feel
was working and he would just start
laughing and then oh my god but i
realized what he was doing if he forgot
they and they told me they said if he
forgets his lines
don't tell him and it could be a minute
two minutes and like i'm just tempted to
do it a lot of times but he would then
start laughing just laughing talk about
that i was like what the [ __ ] not being
i'm not talking about fearless like what
the [ __ ] is he laughing at and then i
realized it bought him time to think of
what the lineup that's
incredible that's right there was a
moment in this one scene where he
we weren't getting it and so we'd do the
curtain call and then and i was standing
next to the current call today he'd be
um
we would be taking he loved he said
bring your friends bring your friends
over to the you know
that's awesome he liked girls did the
young girls
hang around and yeah he'd say there's
some boobies in the third row you know
ezra bowing
but he but
he'd say look little john let's let's
work on that scene so we would go it was
a juvenile word
for somebody with such a that yes i
don't know if it was that yeah yeah it
was derogatory but um no no no no i
don't think it's derogatory but
obviously
um
and then it was a saturday night and the
show was closing on a sunday and to
curtin a little john let's go work on
that i go we've got one more performance
that's incredible that's that's giving a
hundred percent wow
yeah yeah every moment everything he
could give at that and he did
that's awesome
you finish and then i've just done you
know a remarkable three and a half hour
show with with the greatest and you go
out to sign autographs and i was like
how what's michelle like can you say
have mercy oh right yeah at that point i
was like [ __ ] it i don't care anymore
all right great let's let's do fuller
house let's do fullest houses every
[ __ ] thing doesn't matter that's
right you know fill up the whole house
build the whole house i don't give a
[ __ ] anymore and that's when you know
and then then you go okay i'm free oh
yeah is it that because it's no longer
your ego is no longer attached to it
good or bad one it doesn't matter right
because people are still going to
remember you what do they remember you
most from dodgeball um
yeah it's a i mean i guess it sort of
depends but um well i'll tell you john
to your point it's not usually the
things that you're most proud of but
what it is i also noticed the difference
between because i love this part there's
something about this podcast that is i
take it more to heart i guess because
it's so
personal it's it's just us and so so
and then i conversely that's why i can't
read reviews because if somebody said
they hate it it's like i don't like you
it's like i don't like your personality
yeah yeah yeah it's you yeah yeah
there's a really hard point
these podcasts are interesting i don't
do a lot of them because
first of all i listen to a lot and i
don't think i'm interesting enough or i
don't i don't have the memory that a lot
of people do in seventh grade i did this
and i took it right i have a terrible
yeah yeah you know they and they can be
so so articulate speak so much about you
know choices in life i don't i don't i
remember a lot but you have great story
i mean i wouldn't sell yourself sure and
you're doing one now so the one you're
doing now doesn't yeah let's go to that
it doesn't really rely on
that recall your memory because it is
it's what we'll tell people about it's
for wondering which we love this is a
wonderful show so laundry you'd love
them right i it just we just uh started
you started so how did that happen how
did that come to be
so so here's it's just do you know the
story it's fascinating
yeah it's a crime so yeah a lot of
people don't know that this happened but
frank's in 1963 frank sinatra jr was
kidnapped and by this by this guy named
barry keenan who who's 82 now and become
one of my my best friends and i have the
rights to do uh i'm working on a lot of
stuff with the story because it's so
fascinating
it's it falls somewhere between you know
the coen brothers and the marx brothers
yeah i mean it was sort of a comical
like just a
comedy of errors and so this guy bear so
through the beach boys jen and dean were
also you know beach boy type i love
janet dean yeah
little lady from pasadena and dead man's
carbon obviously yeah i was going to go
where is my baby that one no that's not
oh no no no uh that's uh
what do you think of dead man's dad mass
curve yeah how does that go yeah of
course man it's good nothing like a
world worth
that's about a well it's about a girl
who dies right yeah i think buddy how
was that was that buddy holly no
no
i got to get to heaven so yeah she dies
in the car
so i can see my baby
oh maybe that's what i'm thinking just
the whole death through the cars
there you go so it's janet dean and
we're uh we're at the orange county fair
and dean torrance turns to me says you
do some producing right and he says i
got this uh this friend of mine i loaned
him a bunch of money to kidnap frank
sinatra jr and i go
what a crazy thing to say casually right
and i said well let me see any and he
where's that manuscript oh my god wait
this is dean this is jan from jenna
dean torres from toronto so so barry and
dean went to this high school called uni
high out here and it was jim brolin and
ryan o'neal and all these younger
soon to be very successful
people and barry keenan was this upper
middle class kid very very intelligent
uh very strict uh catholic upbringing
in in the way of like you're going to go
to hell if you don't do this
so he gets into
a lot of debt his parents could have
broke and he went broke and he was a bit
of a schmoozer you know a bit of a
bullshitter yeah and he's sitting in his
car one day on the on a bluff looking
over uh catalina island in balboa on the
the radio
god tells him to go kidnap somebody
that's how he's going to get out of his
he'll he owe 240 000. he had it all
figured out if i if i get 240 thousand
dollars i can invest in that invest in
this pay my parents back pay this bill
get this off get a new car do that um
and so he
went ahead and did it he at first he
thought he would kidnap bob hope because
bob hope's son i'm sorry he um
realized oh wait no bob hope is like an
american treasure he goes overseas he's
the u.s oh god
what about sinatra like he's a mod
the dumbest thing right he's a mob guy
people don't really care he's like
connected
right guys and so he he picks frank
sinatra jr he pulls it off oh this is
going to be this would make an amazing
cone brothers this is right it is it is
it is so he goes to jail for and the
trial was a [ __ ] show
you know they started with this thing
sinatra was there oh kill him oh and god
for 50 years or longer there's been you
know he's been shot at like five six
times i bet cause sinatra yeah i mean
like you know i'm not telling you but he
was he was so kid he was the most
connected guy what a story what a great
story
so it's me just basically narrating uh
all of it in 10 or 12 episodes but you
have the people you have the actual
participants i mean those of whom are
still alive i guess well most most are
not so it's just barry it's just burying
his own words and
we sort of it feels immersive you feel
kind of like in a movie because with
sound effects and that is so cool oh man
what a great i can't wait for that
that's great
it's really interesting i have sinatra's
look at this i have sinatra's phone this
last phone book that he had oh my god
he's holding challenges john's holding
up a little tiny like not leather bound
but what is that kind of little
little beige yes pluthery brown wow
that's his last phone book
yeah so it has and just and this is not
funny it's all his writing ted agnew
um
how did you get that from
i bought it oh wow you like started out
of his casket yeah he likes stuff yeah i
like stuff that was smokey that's sammy
davis smokey
yours by the way you're sammy davis is
just phenomenal that that bad i have bad
that's a great uh do you have a sami not
really no in fact
no that sounded like emmy rossum miami
uh
that's really good he said to me i saw
him carrie grant look at that character
oh my god john's holding up very grand
do you have a carry grant no no no
no i haven't seen enough of him sammy
said uh i was at a concert so i tried to
stay friends with him he was you know he
was
you know he was he was bigger than life
but i saw him at the i think it was at
the greek and i was backstage and he had
cancer
and he died not long after but he was
pouring me he was pouring an orange
crush and he poured me an orange crush
and said soda
yeah oh yeah
because he had to you know clean up he
said he said the drugs and the he said
the drugs and the cigs i don't miss the
booze i missed i was like yeah well
it's amazing what do you miss john
oh god that's a good question i don't
really i certainly don't miss the booze
yeah
no i don't miss it i i mean i couldn't
again going back to like being clear and
clear-headed clear yes i mean
and not being
you know
i started going on therapy quite a while
ago and he said your life you're like a
[ __ ] a porpoise orgy slow stop it
just
fuzzy and all over the place and now you
can be clear and folks and also having a
kid like i wake up you know at six
o'clock or 5 30 with him and i'm like
can you imagine being hungover no way
time yeah i i couldn't i am full of
gratitude as they say
it's and that's the important thing
right and i know you do you just step
back and go oh god i know yeah i'm lucky
i know
well speaking of gratitude and exes and
i have to ask you about jerry o'connell
is just sherry is are you friends with
him yeah we're fred he's friend of the
show
he pretends to not listen but he does
listen no he's listening to this he's
listening he's listening to this
you gotta ask him you gotta talk to
ask john about me um i know what he said
no no no no no i i can imagine him
saying i just love teasing him about how
he how handsome you are
he's
always he mentions it all the time
though does he well he you know and i
mean we sort of moved near them oh
really
i haven't i haven't
i haven't seen her talk to her he he's
funny about it i've seen some stuff that
he said he was saying like his kids
watched full house yeah i was their dad
or something yeah he's a funny guy
that's a guy who works
oh my god works hard huh works hard
works a lot uh yeah in fact he was in
that play i did we were talking about uh
my one and only time on broadway that
wasn't very long ago right now two
couple years ago eight years ago
seven eight years ago oh okay yeah but
you're just right i remember that jerry
loves to work he's one of those guys he
just you know
you guys hang out do you enjoy
yeah i haven't seen uh you know i did
see him a couple months ago um yeah
anywho uh that's how is that how he
talks that's how he pivots um if
anything now i'm gonna
anywho
uh and you have a lightning round um
i think they're you know i'm happy for
the yeah yeah look it's it's that's it
that's just letting go we're just like
good god bless you guys it's good yeah
it's nice to hear you yeah nice but it
took me a long long time to get to any
of that yeah yeah why are you in connect
did you have to move back with your
parents are you yes you have to talk
about sitcom no i moved uh shortly
before the pandemic and it was actually
good timing because uh you know i was
close enough to them they're very
stubborn and they were wanting to go out
and get their groceries and all that so
i was able to love this
they're both teachers too huh yes my mom
was an actress when i started when i was
right right right starting out starting
out in life um so i kind of grew up uh
you know which is why i think john i
alluded to this earlier i didn't have
any delusions of grandeur about
the business or the the potential for
uh being
a known person any of that stuff was
like that was not even on my radar it
was just like
when i made the choice to want to be an
actor when i realized i loved it was um
i always thought i'd do a version of
what she did which is like
you know you do theater and then you do
a commercial here and there and uh maybe
you get an episode of an nypd blue or
something yeah um
svu did she did she teach acting too she
did in high school so she so
she once my older brother went to
college we needed you know we
uh
we started needing fun looking at the
finances and sure and she
became a teacher to because that's where
all the money is
so did she all right did she and boy
what on unsung heroes the teachers are
here
both of my sister's teachers so did she
give you notes would she watch them
because now why did you now that choice
did she help did you ever go to her and
say could you help me with the script or
that's a good yes you know what she does
for me all the time still which i love
is um because i like to record
especially if i'm doing a play i i'm
sure you do the same i like to record
all the lines the other person signs
yeah yeah so she does that for me and
she'll say
yeah she'll you know she was very upset
once when i uh i did a play up at
williamstown which
was jerry jerry was in it living on love
it was called and it was a few you and
jerry do everything together we do a lot
of stuff together
oh that's it i'd love to
that's a good idea i would love to do
that jerry what about me you and me
would do well with that we would be a
good we would be a good odd couple
yeah well jerry you know there's
something about jerry that's so now i'm
thinking of walter matthau i guess just
because he's i worked with him too you
did it was great what was he i just
heard kevin pollock tell a great what
was he what'd you do with him it was
towards the end of his life too and it
was it was this tv movie shitty tv movie
and they i remember they offered it to
me and offered like a half a million
dollars which was a lot of money yeah
and i was so bad the script was so bad
and it was it was about like this guy
this son and his parents were uh the
mother dies and so the father's dating
again and the son doesn't like it and
yeah he said no thank pass past and then
i was reading that carol walter mather
and carol burnett were going to play the
two the two of those oh my
screaming
okay i'll do it i'll do this yeah you
know we gave up all the we gave
carol the money
you can do it for 50 grand oh that's so
funny what was he like was it did it
look cuz
i heard he was uh he loved gambling i
heard yeah he got pa his pr he got per
diem you know like we do on the on these
things they give you 50 bucks a day but
his was like a 2 000 or 3 000 just right
he was so he was and i i i
as we've talked about during this eight
hour uh conversation i've i've gravitate
towards older you know men
that type of father figure but it didn't
really happen with him he was so
intelligent he was so he was so smart
that we didn't really couldn't have a
conversation you know i could at that
point in my life i couldn't he was he
wants to talk about art and really music
and i'm like how about the beach bars
but he was uh
he was great he told great stories
you know
wow
carol burnett jesus i love that you
cultivate these relationships i love
that like with don rickles you actually
went out you know if you you know
yeah you i mean you should i don't know
if you do it but like
a lot of these old guys you go hey can i
take you to lunch yeah great yeah
they're sitting around you know
twiddling their thumbs half the time
yeah so you you have to be proactive
about it yeah now slowly i'm turning
into that old guy young kids are going
hey
well it's also i love talking about
people's lives as you know you know and
there's nobody better in that regard
than an older person i mean right they
loved you'd think that the last thing
they want to talk about was the all the
old story stuff but they that's what
they that's them they got they got it
right john i think often about this um
there's this great song i i don't know
if it's john prine who wrote it um but i
i know that joan baez did a cover it's
called hello in there do you know that
song hello yeah yeah yeah bette midler i
think did did that did uh
saying that as well oh really well it's
just beautiful look it up it is john
prime that is a beautiful it's about
some an older person alzheimer's or
something right well yeah and just
looking in these windows i mean i was
you know and looking and imagining the
life the lives that are in there the the
wealth
you know um hello in there uh it's
really touching and and losing and that
they lost friends in korea
there's a great line we lost johnny and
the korean war still don't know what for
oh yes
this segment is brought to you by
i don't even think i have to say but i
will bud light seltzer iced tea and bud
light seltzer lemonade both of them are
they're co-sponsoring this segment the
perfect combination for summer let's
face it it's a boozy arnold palmer they
go together like lazy afternoons and
fishing like peas and carrots this is
called spill the tea and
we're gonna share something that we're
excited about i'm so excited to watch
live music again christian was kind
enough to buy some tickets that he
invited me to for a live concert event
john williams at tanglewood in the
berkshires do you know what might
compliment this evening very nicely bud
light seltzer yeah oh yeah of course
we're going to bring some by lights out
so because bud light seltzer is going to
help us stay refreshed every can it is
five percent alcohol and a hundred
calories and gluten free and the bud
light seltzer lemonade variety pack and
the brand new bud light seltzer ice tea
variety pack and if you really want to
try them all you can get them together
in the bud light seltzer ice tea and
lemonade mix pack you could test every
permutation out and find your favorite
combination of iced tea and lemonade
that'd be a fun like you know like peach
iced tea and lemonade actual lemonade or
you know just find your favorite
combination you can get all the
different flavors of bud light seltzer
delivered at bud light.com
delivery or
you like the old fashioned i like the
old-fashioned way where you go to a
store
a grocery store a convenience store
liquor store and um have a human
interaction with someone who works there
and pick up a pack yourself and get out
in the world
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello hello again
we'll meet again
[Music]
okay uh man you're so this is so fun i i
could do this for hours i i know your
time's limited and i we have a lightning
round
oh oh we do i thought you were kidding
no no is that all right it's it'll be
what i'll do whatever you want but
you're so this is such an interesting
smart conversation you'll be like what's
your favorite color oh well that's
coming okay
what is your most commonly used emoji
would you say i don't use emojis i never
like here's the deal if you're past 50
stop using emojis okay it's silly right
yeah yeah
you're never attempted to were you in an
emoji movie no never
tru honest to god you've never used an
emoji
no i don't think so
i had something that looked like me if
you saw oh okay okay but
um no and also here's another pet people
is wrong
if you're texting somebody and you text
text text sex and then you're done
you're done and then you look oh there's
another text okay i gotta go check it
and it's just like a thumbs up it's on
the text oh yeah
right you're going back to think that
there's something there and there's
nothing right there's a [ __ ]
that's yeah that's that's annoying
that's something that only people who
get text a lot of texts
will be annoyed by um i imagine you get
a lot of text hey when's the next beach
boys uh tour
well this summer there's a lot of shows
coming up and depending on my day job i
think i'm going to go do a bunch uh this
is airing after but i'm do we're playing
in san diego um this weekend at the at
the
enormous dome or whatever it was padre
stadium oh man i love that stadium uh
what a great i loved san diego uh okay
if you could be a professional athlete
what sport would you play and why your
this interview was so great until now oh
really well then that's pat what kidding
i'm kidding well
i i don't know i'm not an athlete you're
not an athlete sports you're not
interested in any sports huh no my dad
used to say you go out of your way to
hate sports i was like i just don't i
don't connect to it but i'm telling you
watch the show because i it's all about
basketball yeah yeah so are you learning
more about basketball have you found
yourself watching basketball no okay i'm
a good i'm a good actor it was easier to
to remember the the the medical jargon
in er than it is oh real basketball
stuff yeah really
i always are you a basketball fan yeah
yeah i love basketball yeah so a friend
of mine knew jerry west
and who connected me with him i told
this story a bunch but i went to i went
to hang out with him i said mr west
thank you for inviting me to this
rehearsal first of all it's not a
rehearsal it's practice that's funny
and it just went on like that yeah yeah
um if you could have one snack food for
the rest of your life uh do you smoke
weed are you a week or did you back in
the day no no no i never got into that
what is that oh because you smoke pot
and you have i like these i like
crackers crackers i snack too much uh
what types of crackers like oyster
crackers no like nut fins i'm looking at
it oh i love a good nut thing right yeah
um uh this oh this is a good one for you
what is your
oh a movie i'm curious about a movie
that you're excited to show your son uh
you're uh
willy wonka we've been watching uh um
yeah we've been watching we watch grease
he loves singing in the rain he loves uh
uh make him laugh we play that all the
time oh cool i started showing him stuff
pretty early he loves and i gotta i
gotta tell him because i worked with him
and bye bye birdie he loves bill irwin
and oh bill
yeah yeah he's a genius and we she's he
loves bits by the way well bill armand
is the king of those the king so we've
been we were watching some videos of
bill and he you know billy my son's like
doing this stuff and i gotta get a hold
of bill i gotta tell him what what would
be your go-to karaoke song i don't like
karaoke you don't no
well because you get to do it i mean i
asked bon jovi the same thing and he was
like karaoke yeah i
i yeah well that's what i do i go but
have you ever um you've never been
tempted you're right you're back in the
day
i don't know i mean i don't i mean
and and
you know you go to karaoke or if people
are there's a karaoke there people are
salivating to get up i don't i don't
want to take their i know that's true
you know other places if you had to um
if you had to get a tattoo do you have
tattoos you do i don't have any i would
get a i would get i want to get one
though because now that i'm older how
much longer do i have to deal with but
you have to
cover them all the time with you know
that's the thing for actors yeah so
where would you get it on uh i guess
wherever it's whatever's not going to be
seen your teens or something i would get
one taint or above right above this it
said if you could if you could read this
you're blowing me okay yes yeah right
yeah or
or i may have that already
yeah or you're just or i respect you
because you're you're just a very short
person
um
right right right yeah samurai has a
joke um i don't know i know it's just a
tiger have you been saying do you know
bob i know bob a little bit yeah a
little bit in fact i think i've seen
hang out with him with john mayer yeah i
hate buddies yeah it'd be funny john if
you got canceled for quoting bob saget
well i could
seriously but he has a joke about like
uh
um
my my ex-wife is this tall i'm not i'm
not sober oh yeah that sounds like a bob
saget yeah was it was it was he always
doing [ __ ] like that on the set were you
like uh was he making those blue jokes
did it have to come out of him because
it was such a family show
yes he was like that anyway you know he
has tourette's but he uh he couldn't
help it but um
it was and we've talked about this he's
one of my he's like my brother i love
him so much yeah but it was distracting
i was coming from an acting point you
know point of view and these guys were
comics and they were just trying to
right you know make every the crew laugh
you know yeah here's the does it put in
the [ __ ] script getting up with wiley
pulling the chords who cares oh right
they would it was distracting oh that's
so funny um who was your first celebrity
crush
well like uh maybe suzanne summers oh
yeah or fair fawcett but suzanne summers
i think for sure come and knock on my
door
and then you meet him right and go oh
god well that's the thing i was going to
ask you yeah i know is it even years
later it's like you must regret i i find
myself regressing back to that time
who's who was yours um well meg ryan was
a big one i remember meeting meg uh
doing working with her and
couldn't have been nicer and
fortunate
oh
yeah of course yeah but the same with
brooke it's like it's so different than
she is in your
head from back in the day you know yes
yeah some of them were some of them were
just exactly the same
you know
i used to go on these car shows by the
way like this this last 10 minutes is
all you should really put on this thing
yeah now we got interesting so yeah the
last round that you pooh-poohed you're
right you're right i used to go on these
car shows where they would you know you
you would sign autographs and and and
make cash and i would come home with ten
thousand dollars in cash and this is my
dad you know again with my dad i come
home and yeah he'd say uh
you know i'd say uh he'd say go clean
the dog crap in the backyard i said [ __ ]
you i got ten thousand dollars in
cashiers i don't give a
[ __ ] oh that's interesting but you'd go
on these shows and they would send
either like it would be like me and 10
playmates or me and heather locklear
heather thomas and heather you know
something else right and so you'd meet
some of those girls there i took how
it's during there we went there one
night of course movies late but i was
not i wasn't that guy i was i always
wanted to be in a relationship i didn't
want to date i didn't want to chase oh
funny
i wanted to be in a relationship i was
trying i guess i wanted both um yeah
well
yeah well it's funny the first time i
met drew was we went to a party at the
mansion
i've always had a crush on her yeah if
that's oh she's the best i mean how yeah
yeah the funniest
just coolest i get that but that's the
kind of thing it's like you can't spend
that much time with somebody and like
like somebody that much and then it just
did it just goes i don't know that to me
is very difficult i think that's why
i think she thinks similarly like i
think that's why we both make the effort
to i you would think that but i've had a
relationship for it or yeah it didn't
but but right but what you said about
four hours ago was right was like god
we've shared the most intimate moments
we've done incredible things together
families
and how could you not talk to that
person but i know
i know i agree
i agree with myself from four hours ago
um uh so what is that what's the tattoo
john
we're back to that yeah well i don't
have one oh no no but that you're gonna
get
you a picture of it oh okay that took a
weird turn that would be amazing
but the apple you not the
you switched didn't you you went to the
the yeah i did intel commercials yeah
yeah uh
i'll do the intel justin okay good
everyone's a better a better me uh
what's your favorite fruit speaking of
me
[Music]
watermelon oh watermelons are great yeah
all these great uh
questions about life and thing and then
what's your favorite fruit well fruit is
such a big part of life
yeah but it's okay
what do you think is too basic i like
going good you know blueberries are good
yeah what about you um i'd like both of
those i think if i had to pick one a a
ripe mango like a those are good now you
got me it's tough to have to turn down a
mango man especially when they cut them
like
oh yeah but especially in like when
you're in those countries because i
never had one in central america a
papaya too papaya to me always tasted
like vomit or like smelled a little bit
of vomit
i could hear people trying to careen
their cars off into a yeah okay
oh like that janet dean song full circle
there you go um uh who would you want to
play you in the biopic in your biopic
you oh man i could never i'd be way too
self-conscious about not being handsome
enough there's there was a there was a
really shitty life uh lifetime movie
about full house i think it's some you
know oh really who played you i don't
know who he was he was an actor he was
better looking than me i was pissed off
um the beetles or the rolling stones
would you prefer
stones
no beetles come on ketchup or mustard
you're gonna shame me for this question
you're you're having a hot dog i don't
eat hot dogs i don't eat hot dogs yeah i
don't like ketchup yeah okay so mustard
okay great okay this is how we're gonna
end some of the best this is one of the
best no no no no no i gotta forget i
want two adjectives from you john that
you would want you hope people describe
you with these two words that you're
you're able to listen to your
the eulogies right at your funeral
what would you want to hear kind and
welcome
oh no yeah those are technically yeah
those are two are those
you know funny uh what do you why you're
hung
yeah finally hung decently hung
what are your two uh kind i like um
funny
oh yeah i mean i know it's like
you know what are the things you value
the most i i think i value humor and
kindness the most yeah
so you and i should die at the same time
and they can save money on the
writing the eulogy yeah and uh you know
if it's a slow news day maybe
i wonder who are you a trend ahead of me
you were trending justin you you have
exceeded everything that i thought you
would be uh i'm a fan of yours you're
like
you're smart you're a great actor and i
appreciate you having me on here and um
i wish we could talk forever but um
shave again that's right well john
likewise this has been so fun thank you
don't hang out in person some time and
and i mean i thought of you as a good
guy and then here you are well thanks
john i'm looking forward to all of these
things um
say hi to your brother and tell them
that when i say that it looks like the
wax figure of you i i mean it in the
highest okay well i can't wait for his
reaction you'll hear his reaction if you
listen to that and i i still thank you
for listening that's really cool of you
have mercy have mercy it wasn't that his
catchphrase um it wasn't that the olsen
twins no theirs was like hey dude or
like no half mercy was uh stephanie was
jody sweden wasn't it
no i thought it was i thought it was
half mercy
no it wasn't it was stephanie tanner it
was i'm pretty sure in what context
what context would john stamos say i
don't know like he's so sexy he's like
oh i have mercy it was like an elvis
thing wasn't it wasn't his character
really like fancied himself like elvis
hey
and he would do his like elvis
act on it kind of need to hold on yeah
have mercy i'm pretty sure it's him
maybe you're right
i have mercy
mercy yeah
it was like he was so like turned on i
uh
stand corrected that's how he said it
it's weird now it's weirder that you
thought it was jody sweet and you said
it i thought it was a cutesy like a
precocious maybe she said it once or
twice i'm sure like they were running
out of stuff to do on that show i'm sure
she said it once or twice just as i'm
sure but she said hey dude things like
that right i bet bob saget no i think
the twins have mercy have mercy and like
what was dave cooley is was cut it out
that's right i remember that and what
was bob saggett's did he have one
uh he was just like life he was like you
remember full house that well well i
have mercy you know what i think i
remember because it was on that hulu
commercial for a while where they did
like blurg like tina fey doing her
catchphrase oh you're right you're right
instead i think that's still on it's on
a lot yeah have mercy but what i didn't
remember that that just reminded me was
that which is weird to me that he did it
in like moments of like
arousal like he goes have mercy like
flirt like he was like damn she's hot
like that's how he that's the context in
which he's so strange did you think
about uh talking to him about
laurie laughlin
isn't this weird you know it crossed my
mind really
no and even if it had crossed my mind i
i i would have been really wanted to
make
if that was something that was you had
to resist yourself no because it's not a
scandal that it's that is ever really on
my mind i have opinions about what she
did of course and um
i'm i guess i'm kind of curious to hear
his thoughts but i but not enough so to
make him to to risk him being
uncomfortable should we call jerry yes
yes okay so
do you hear that chair you got to fix it
to become part of the podcast talking
about how you haven't fixed the chair
maybe subconsciously i i like that part
of it so i don't want to
so you're calling jerry o'connell front
of the show best friend of the show best
friend of the show and uh
is somewhat related to john it's demos
as we've talked about
i have a feeling he might not pick up
if he doesn't pick up we'll try him
again
we should also say why he's not picking
up
because i made a mistake
speaking of not wanting to make people
feel uncomfortable i made a rookie
mistake
so jerry we had just called jerry he
excitedly picked up and we said can i
call you back in five minutes and we
said sure we you'll be on the show then
because we're going to record for the
podcast and he said great
and he did call back in five minutes and
we said oh we're not quite ready can you
call back again sure and we'll be
talking about and it's the john stamos
episode
i don't think you made a mistake at all
really no because it's i think respect
for the talent i think that's the maybe
the reason he's
not picking up now i do too but i also
think it would be unfair and and
yeah borderline shitty it's shitty put
him on the spot if you didn't tell him i
know because as listeners may know yeah
jerry's wife
used to be married to john stamos yeah
and but see the reason why we're being
kind of like
fun and flip about it is because jerry
is often fun and flip about it like he's
established that tone he's allowed to i
know do that if he wants to do that on
his terms on his terms right but i don't
think it's up to you
to put him on the spot you're right let
me calm again
i
you're right i mean i agree with
everything you're saying
hey i'm gonna call you back
in one second okay cool okay okay
okay so
uh we'll wait for cherries
by the way jerry o'connell
uh now yes the the first ever
male co-host of the talk yeah he's what
would you say about that that he's
breaking a a glass bottom
he's he's breaking a glass
yeah it's certainly not a ceiling um
or maybe it's a different type of
ceiling
i like glass base yeah he's breaking the
glass basement
if i say that to him do you think he'll
get it right away do you think i'll
laugh
um i think he'll get it cause he's smart
yeah he is smart i don't know if he'll
laugh though
but this is big news this is like
big news and entertainment and i think
us talking to him about it right now is
the scoop yeah and hearing how he feels
about it i'm also curious what he thinks
about john's stamina me too
you know both i'm arguably more
interested
[Laughter]
okay well we're about to hear from the
the new
co-host of the talk
okay here he is yay
[Applause]
whoa you have a newfound there's an
energy in your voice that i haven't
heard since you've become the new male
host of the talk
uh wait
jerry i actually haven't talked to you
about this how do i even know it was
like in the works
how did how did that happen
yeah um
you know they've had uh some
transitions with hosts on that show
um
and um
i got a call in march
wow and they said they need someone to
come in for a day uh-huh
and this is when they were going through
recently a lot of their turmoil and i
was like
oh i don't know about that it seems like
a crazy place you know i didn't really
know exactly it does seem like a crazy
place it's just like there was fighting
yeah
yeah there's a lot of fighting you have
enough of that at home with the twins
well i mean it's not that i have a
volatile household it's just that um
i want to go somewhere where there's
no arguing you know utopian society
yeah well maybe you can help create that
on the talk so i went in for a day and
they immediately said
can you do it for a month
wow
so i did it for a month and then after a
month i said um
we would like to make you permanent wow
that's really cool um you know of course
we always root for you and you're so
good at doing that stuff you're so good
at hosting those shows so it's gonna be
fun to watch everything
and you remember this it started when
regis philbin um god rest his soul got
ill
that's right that's right with you and
kelly i filled in with kelly
because i was doing the play with you
that's right you were already in new
york and like
did i ever tell you
the first time i co-hosted that show
what i'm pretty sure i was with you and
christian chris is there right yeah
craig yeah i i'm pretty sure hey jerry
here's the problem justin couldn't find
the cord justin couldn't find the cord
to
plug the phone in so i'm far from the
phone so i don't want to yell
i kind of like i like that image that i
have you and christian are really linked
to this oh okay
so you and i were doing a play in new
york
we were going to bars and we were
drinking late into the night not that
all right because i like degeneres
like it's like cruising
you must stay until 2 a.m okay yeah fine
sometimes later wait man so a week
before
i went to go do live with regis and
kelly to promote our play and i got
bumped and when you get bumped you're
like ethnics yeah life like this so then
i went out a week passes
regis god rest his soul got ill or
something uh-huh
i was with you at a little uh a little
establishment called the cabin i was
with you and christian the cabin down
below yeah new york speaking of r.i.p we
were drinking and it was i'd say around
10 30 or 11 it was just when our night
was getting going
and my phone rang
it was the booker from
regis and kelly
boyce he's like this she's like no
nonsense
and she went
i need you on the show tomorrow um
mph mrs
i was like oh gosh it was your instinct
to be like ah no not after what happened
um it was a little bit but i was like
okay i'll come in right yeah so i stayed
out till two or two thirty
and thought to myself
it doesn't matter i'm gonna get bumped
anyway
whoever martin short is gonna do three
segments and i'm never
gonna get on alarm
i said it for eight
you know
i finally fit in the shower splash my
face with cold water put a call through
my hair i get on the train and i go up
there and i get there at around
like 8 55 i like to get there when they
walk in you know yeah because i'm pretty
hungover
probably
you know it's just to take a dark turn i
didn't know so you were drunk still
i was drunk
oh boy okay
so anyway i get there and they
immediately mic me up and gilman who's
the producer there starts talking to me
about the stories and everything and i
was like hey tell them chill out i have
a couple stories from the play that uh
i'm doing with jaylon kelly ripa comes
out of the room and takes my arm and we
start walking toward the stage
and i was like oh my gosh kelly i gotta
admit i was out tall like way late last
night she was like oh my gosh i can kind
of tell but kelly's cool like kelly gets
it yeah yeah she's she is so fun today
we're gonna have so much fun i can't
wait and i was like yeah i can't wait
too you know i gotta i got some good
jaylon bits
she was like all right well you know
we'll just go out there it'll be 20
minutes and then uh
and then and then we'll just do the rest
of the show it's a piece of cake and i
was like
20 minutes and she went yeah and we're
standing right on stage she goes you're
hosting today oh wow and
uh live with regis and kelly with jerry
o'connell and kelly riley you didn't
know you were posting
oh my god
i didn't think it was going there oh how
badly do you want to see this is there
is it on youtube
you know i've never actually looked at
it oh my god
it's hilarious
wait so what's the lesson here it ended
up leading to this new job yeah it ended
up being a good thing but whatever i did
kelly said at the end of the episode
like oh my gosh
like
we need some help because um
my co-host is uh taking a little bit of
a leave you're coming back how long you
went down and i went back and did like
30. oh so the lesson is do do you now
feel the need to get like really drunk
the night
you know before know a lot of stand-ups
and stuff who basically stand up their
their job is at a bar yeah and
it's a really bad habit to get into
having a couple drinks before you go oh
yeah on my own yeah
you know what ends up being just two
shots before your show
quickly becomes five shots quickly
becomes a bottle and then well it's your
i've always wondered like for i mean
that aside that is interesting but like
now that you're gonna be doing this
regularly what if somebody comes on the
show that you have
a history with that you're not like what
if it's like your wife's like
ex or something like that are you
allowed to say whether or not you want
to
talk about that
you know what's funny like if john
stamos came on
our guest today you know i don't know if
i told you this but i guess is john
stamos this episode was john stamos we
just talked to him and he said very nice
things very nice things so we thought oh
my god what a nice what a nice book end
to this episode to like
justin kristen that's what you don't
that's not the that's not what you tell
me when you first call me yeah i told
you that
i told you that
this is the first i'm hearing it no it's
not oh you said it on the list
i said it on the phone
justin kristen i love you but this is
you're quickly turning your show into
like maury i said it on the phone listen
we're not trying to stir up any garbage
he said nice things i know you'd say
nice things let's leave it at that
you're turning into
get out of here
seems like a great guy yeah uh he does
he recently moved uh very close to uh my
family and i no kidding so so my kids
have a joke where they uh
oh he's like when we're driving we're
like
like my kids are always like there he is
there he is
because my kids are dying to meet him
you know
awesome my kids are infatuated with them
i mean obviously because of the um full
house thing it's well also he's having a
great another new show i forget what it
is big shot big shot
just kids love that show and also they
love teasing you your kids are really
funny
because they love teasing me
it's like
it's so funny like explaining to kids
one of their parents was previously
married and at first what it must be
weird
like i have one daughter
really uh
really lays into the joke of me uh-huh
she's a real rascal
if he ever comes on tv she like elbows
me and she goes
[Laughter]
don't ever read comments anymore oh
interesting yeah because a lot of
comments which you know basically boil
things down to their sympathy oh yeah
they're live
i can't believe
rebecca romain is with terry o'connell
john stamos is so much better looking
i was like
i got to stop reading this yeah i know
and like even though it's like it's
petty and it's juvenile but still it's
like that thing when you're
it's no one he sounded a little
maybe not jealous but like a little
squirrely about jerry yeah so jerry i
mean just remember like
you won i don't
i remember i was care deep on a comment
i was going deep on a comment section
once
and someone wrote i can't believe
she's not like i can't believe she's
jerry o'connell yeah just he's so much
uglier
than john stamos and then someone
replied to that comment and wrote you
know you shouldn't talk like that and i
was like okay finally something someone
defending me yeah
and someone wrote you shouldn't talk
like that yes he is uglier but you don't
know
there could be something else it's
it's unclear at this point i am a father
and i have two 12 year old girls
and you know it's kind of been my major
responsibility in the last 12 years and
i say to my daughters
every day the most important thing is
to have a laugh and be funny about
things it's the most important it's true
i love that that mentality that mindset
we try to employ that here on life
assurance
it would be so fun to do a hang with uh
with my wife's ex it would be oh my god
i don't know if that's in the car i
don't know how that you know what
i bet they'd get along too i think you
get along and i think i'm in a position
to maybe facilitate that and if i can do
anything in this lifetime
for personalities
congrats jerry yeah congrats jerry
seriously
buddy really truly congrats that's a big
thing i'm i'm proud of you i'm happy for
you
see you guys
we didn't we did it for the record but
it was entertaining right
[Music]
monumental that happened that i might it
might be not monumental uh now i feel
bad that he was blindsided a little bit
you know what i had you did say it i but
by the way i thought that was very funny
and i had a feeling
i said i thought he had met him but i
guess not i guess they've never met so
funny so i now am excited about the
prospect of
setting them up i love that his
daughters tease him i know i know and
that's really funny
um
and that was uh
very appropriate that he was on this
episode i'm glad we did that me too and
i hope uh i hope you enjoyed that
everyone life is short listeners have to
love jerry jerry's like uh he's if there
were a third host it'd be him back to
john stamos yes
john stamos and you i thought really hit
it off i did too like really hit it off
well you know you're cut from a similar
cloth you know he eventually not
physical claws
no no we're cut from very different
physical cloths
he's cut from like five like the finest
you know like italian
yeah i know
but i thought you two got along really
well and i think yeah um you had a very
natural rapport yeah well you know he
really admires you i was thinking i was
flattered by him i was but see then i
started to think is he bradley coopering
you or
does he really admire you that much so
what that means is bradley cooper would
um
he would do a thing that was very
intense he would lock into you and and
uh flatter you uh he he did we've talked
about that on the show yeah he basically
he he would i don't know if he still
does this now that he's like the most
famous person on earth yeah he used to
do a thing where he'd go up to you at a
some sort of event i don't think it's
[ __ ] and he would compliment it yeah
to a
and and then you realize that oh he does
that he does that like that's a move
remember the guy at the griddle who
thought that you used to be obese he was
like
he's like well your brother lost a lot
of weight yeah
um but yeah bradley i i don't know if
it's a move i think it might be he's
also an incredible actor but i think
it's
i don't know i think it's just a very
present
i think it's a tactic to be charming
yeah john stamos oh yeah i'm sure he
took the time to look to google me
and he
said that he thought i looked like a wax
figure version of you like you're a wax
well that's what that's what we should
have brought up with jerry when he was
he was expressing his insecurities about
stamos looking good not only do you i'm
sure acknowledge how good-looking he is
you have but that a good-looking guy
like that then
kind of like
[ __ ] signing you're critical of my
critical of your life well first of all
this is what i say about that yeah
i wasn't
exactly sure what the what i mean i knew
it was some sort of insult but i didn't
really get what made it insulting
exactly right but i kind of know what
he's talking about a little bit where
especially certain photos if i look a
little frozen looking or something i've
seen people who look like wax figures of
themselves like like wayne newton always
like
you know in the last couple years he's
started to look like are you comparing
me to wayne newton no no no i'm saying
i'm trying to understand his the cr
criticism of your looks
my point is like
i i think a wax figure look would denote
uh a plastic looking right that's what i
would have thought yeah or if like
some famous person has too much makeup
on or right the light hits them in a
weird way here's the point though it
still probably wouldn't bother me for
two reasons one because john stamos is
so handsome he operates on a different
level of
you know
physical beauty than i ever could
imagine right
two more importantly
i think it's so
weird and cool
and
surreal that john stamos a person that
i've been
so acutely aware of right for like my
entire life really since you were since
i was a little kid
he's so famous to me he said he's the
person i grew up watching on tv the fact
that he
is aware of me and and looked me up even
if his
even if his conclusion was oh that guy
is like unattractive or strange-looking
i still think it's really cool like the
fact that he looked me up trumps
whatever he could say about me it's true
and that's that's how i feel it's also
not it just
in his defense and in the defense of
what he said it's not inherently
insulting i mean like it it might be or
it might be doubly insulting i'm saying
even if it wasn't right right just that
even if he was like i looked up your
brother he's uh he's kind of has like a
strange whatever he has like he has kind
of odd features but he looks like a nice
guy i would be like whoa john stamos
looked me up
that's cool yeah well how about this
john stamos is listening to you now
maybe definitely
he's cool he's cool i'm [ __ ] he's
cool and very affable and i really
appreciate that he said he wanted to be
famous
i think he's a very honest humble person
too and about his and even saying like
even being honest about his insecurities
yes about not being the smartest person
in the room right by the way he seems
plenty smart it's just
he's not formally educated and and it
probably bought who knows what happened
earlier we our insecurities don't always
come from like a real rational place you
know right and that's a good example
he's totally smart who knows where it
comes from but um yeah i really admire
that he was able to be honest about that
and he's a good talker yeah uh
i'm excited to listen to his podcast
yeah it's called snatching sinatra and
that's a crazy story isn't that a great
story jesus
jesus jesus yes um and his show
big shot oh yeah disney plus just get
great reviews uh jerry o'connell's kids
love it
so let's read a letter let's read a
letter okay from bronwyn martin bronwyn
subject comfort through grief and house
hunting would you rather huh hi justin
and christian i'm a new listener and
i've really been enjoying your podcast
one of my favorite parts is how hard
christian makes you laugh sometimes
i have a really good relationship with
my sister like that too that's cool
bronwyn i wonder what her sister's name
is cause that's such an interesting name
um i lost my dog uh i'm sorry bronwyn i
lost my dog a little over a month ago
and it broke me pretty hard she was my
best little friend for over a decade
that sucks and we went through so much
together for almost half my life
wow bronwyn she was my everything and
losing her was one of the hardest things
i've ever gone through
i found your podcast shortly after her
passing and i found some comfort in
laughing with you both and your guests
well i'm glad to hear that i've been
going backwards through the episodes and
just finished listening to the louis
anderson one i've never been a fan of
his comedy but am now a fan of him as a
person
he was so positive in such a bright
light that has really lifted my spirit
and given me a more positive outlook
these days i aspire to be the kind of
genuine authentic and beautiful person
he seems to be i i agree
listening to the real paris hilton and
hearing her story was really interesting
and inspiring as well thank you for
bringing these types of conversations to
the world i feel really good when
listening that is nice to hear thank you
for that bronwyn
that makes that is really nice yeah it
makes us feel good um
thanks to you both bronwyn she her
would you rather
we are going to be house hunting
sorry house shopping soon so in the
spirit of that would you rather
live in a legit haunted house for sure
ghosts up in there for free
i've been thinking about this lately for
free or live in a huge mansion with all
the room you could ever want but you
would never finish paying it off for the
rest of your life
that's funny we were just house shopping
um how shopping and i've been thinking
about this haunted house situation
because we have a movie about a haunted
house uh called lady of the manor which
comes out september 17th wow that was
really good thanks thanks well you're
gonna be good come uh press time
promotional tour
um
uh that is a great question i i haven't
i have an answer yeah you don't both
have to have answers to her would you
rather i i
uh haunted house i would live in a legit
haunted house for free and i'll tell you
why um you're cheap
i'm cheap
yeah
i'm cheap but also uh
i i have a feeling i would this might be
arrogant but i have a feeling i would
get along i would go along with it i was
thinking the same thing even if they
were like tortured spirits i would like
i i i think they would see that i wasn't
a threat
and um i would be i would ingratiate
myself with the ghost i agree
it'd be scary also
also it's not clear that it's a you know
a bad
exact ghost situation it could be a fun
ghost situation uh uh i mean if it was a
haunted house i mean let's face it like
the amityville i wouldn't want to cause
like that movie and the shining they
make you do crazy [ __ ] they'd make you
do murderous stuff i wouldn't want to
leave if it's like that then i would i
would rather not have a home period so
you need the specific the haunting more
more specific you need i need to have
you need the haunting more defined yeah
i guess so but i would need to have
uh i would need to know that there is at
least an option
of winning over a ghost
like i i would need to know that it's
not a situation like that like uh i'm
just being tormented and there's i'm
stuck in this horrible situation because
if that's tormented if that's the case
i'm i'd rather
live on the street yeah exactly but like
think about that how many times have you
heard about even like the all the
anecdotes you hear about haunted houses
none of them are like and then it made
me filled with this murderous rage or
like and that's that's how i lost my
hand or that's how i had my like scalp
burned it's always like oh and they like
this old woman appeared and she just
like was like
i'm picturing ghostbusters now where
she's like in the stacks of books and
like shh
like that kind of app or like a
drawer open drawer oh my god or a
shutter or something yeah or yeah so i i
would do that i guess but here's the
other here's the other reason i would do
it the second option of having this huge
house with all these
i wouldn't want to live in a house
i know um
and
and just you'd want some ghosts in there
to fill it up so aesthetically the first
option sounds kind of cozier
and i mean the ghost would be a
challenge but the house itself sounds
better in the first
half i wouldn't want a massive mansion
but also just bigger picture wouldn't it
just ex like existentially wouldn't it
comfort you to know
that there's other ghosts i mean that's
i think my part of my fascination with
ghosts is that like
i i want to know that that something
happened of course but i don't
necessarily want to live with them i
don't either but like i think i think i
would get used to it
and i i think the ghost would get used
to me and i don't think i'd ever be a
bad roommate for a ghost you might be
thinking too much about our movie you
think you might be and i might be too
because it in my mind right now a
haunted house is like judy grier yeah
it's like a fun place i'm gonna live
with judy
i know that's true why wouldn't want
like ominous scary [ __ ] well once you
said the shining i was like oh maybe i
misunderstood the question i know
because that would be horrible horrible
with like blood coming out of the walls
and like yeah i mean that's
or am i i mean there's something that
like i don't know
bronwyn we would need a little bit more
clarity on the haunting
yeah uh otherwise good question good
question very very good question and
such a nice letter and um
and and thank you for that and thanks to
they're really charming and
honest john stamos very funny too i
think his personality is as attractive
as his face
wow yeah that is quite a compliment yeah
he's like a vulnerable he seems like an
evolved which i know we've said before
on the show
so many people who have gotten sober
seem so evolved to me because they've
done so much work on themselves and he's
no different he really does seem evolved
yeah i all these years he was looking
for mercy and he finally found it oh boy
i saw you trying to i saw your eyes
darting around trying to figure out how
to get that one and i have mercy uh no
he was a great guest yeah and i'm not
just saying that because i want to go to
a beach boys concert i actually believe
that
also we should say if you would like to
write into the show john stamos can
write into the show if he wants you
could write a letter but um anyone could
write into the show and you do that by
emailing a letter to life is short at
wondery.com
so thank you to john stamos and go
listen to his podcast on wandery called
snatching snatcher and his show big shot
disney plus called bigshot yes and
thanks to him and um thanks to all of
you for listening and we will talk to
you very soon
life could be a dream life could be a
dream
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it is co-hosted and produced by you
christian love it's also produced by
megan v monaco i see your producer on
this one michelle miche lance and the
audio engineer today is sergio enriquez
what's that you want to know who the
executive producer is i'll tell you it's
marshall louie for what company
wondering and stay tuned for a voice
memo
[Music]
now now margaret this is also
what if we use this for the voice moment
it's an opportunity for you to say
something to dave coulier for liking
your how much it meant to you that he
liked your comment
[Laughter]
he might be listening
we'll
um what comment did he like of yours
because i said well i didn't say it
sports not said it but you run sports
not yeah
are you trying to get business for
sports not where it's not sports not at
sports not okay then what is it n-a-w-t
um he i wrote something like
i wish that i was watching a hockey game
i can't even remember which one i wish
that dave coulier was commentating this
was doing like color commentary or
something and he liked it and he
freaking loved it he didn't love
he loved it
you